hey what's up it's Gwen Stefani and this
is the wired autocomplete interview
[Music]
I can't believe people are googling this
this is so funny
[Music]
what Gwen Stefani's real name when Rene
Stefani is my name not Wendelin not when
a beer not one of each when and not
Quinn like how Blake says it when it's
one but you can say Queens if you are
what our when's the bonney's children's
names Kingston James McGregor Rossdale
Zuma and Nestor Rock Rossdale and Apollo
Bowie Flynn Rossdale I know it's a lot
of names but I was just so excited to
have kids I couldn't I couldn't decide
what was once the Bonnie's first song
first of all I ever personally had any
part in writing was a song called
different people that song ended up on
Obama's playlist is that weird I mean
how is that even possible but it
happened and yeah that was one of the
first things I ever was part of what was
once the Bonnie's first job my first job
was I was a swim instructor lifeguard at
a pool my second job because everyone
thinks it's my first job but it was
actually my second job was at Dairy
Queen so yeah I started there and my
uniform used to fit like perfectly and
then by the time I ended there it didn't
fit anymore I literally couldn't even
button it up so had to quit what movie
was Wednesday bonyen I've been in a few
movies actually I was in was it called
Zoolander yes I was in that for like two
seconds you might see me in that I was
in the Aviator Martin Scorsese yes that
happened oh yes and I did a voice in an
animated movie it was called trolls yes
I was awesome when Stefani what you
waiting for meaning well it's right
around that song was I was in no doubt
we'd never taken any kind of breaks we
had always worked it was like everybody
was exhausted Adrian had just gotten
married had a baby and so we're gonna
take a break and so what happens here
was I was like I'm making dance record
like I was just
for aspired to go and do that and I went
in the studio to work with some other
writers and Linda Perry from four Non
Blondes was writing a lot of songs at
that time and so I went in the studio
with her and I was telling her about how
I was so like anxious about writing and
insecure and I have writer's block and
all these things and she said what you
waiting for was too funny
and then I came in the next day and she
had this like crazy song and that's how
that song was born
what is one Stefani phone number please
text me guys I I just I feel like I'm
how many friends 8 6 75 3 0 9 what is
Wednesday funny style it's a hot mess
and that's what I like about it ok
there's no rules okay whatever makes you
feel happy and whatever makes other
people feel uncomfortable pretty much so
that I like to do what songs did when
Stefani write a real hollaback girl with
Pharrell I wrote don't speak with Eric
Stefani I've always been a part of you
know in writing all the songs that I've
ever done I've done a cover of it's my
life by top talk with no doubt and
that's actually one of my favorite songs
that to do live and I did not write that
one I did this other song called baby
don't lie which I did not write on it
used to be deep like baby don't cry and
I changed it to be I don't lie that's
not really writing so yeah but typically
everything else that I've ever sung for
the most part has been something that
I'd co-wrote with somebody else
how was once the Pawnee discovered Jimmy
I mean actually from Interscope Records
was the one that kind of discovered me
but I have to kind of give credit to
Tony Ferguson who was an English an our
guy that came over from England I used
to work for stiff records which was a
record company in England that all the
ska bands were part of it was really
like inspiring that he came over and he
saw us at a showcase but then they'd
even goes back further because this guy
and Aaron Murphy who actually set the
showcase up so I would say that
ultimately Jimmy Iovine
that said in six years from now you will
be a star and I was like who are you and
I'm gonna have like ten kids by the time
I'm six years old so I don't know you're
talking about and then six years on the
dot don't speak was never one around the
world so what's up Jimmy how was the
funny ponytail how to do one it's
actually really complicated that would
be something that you would have to ask
my hairdresser oh I could do it I
actually did one for myself the other
day I think the special thing about my
ponytails because there's lots of
different versions is it's just
something that like I've always done and
I think that people kind of like
recognized it from maybe that's just to
grow a video which by the way I did my
own hair and makeup and styling and
everything you know for me it's all
about just being on stage and feeling
comfortable and being able to perform so
that's where the ponytail was born how
is Gwen Stefani and Blake Shelton doing
how are we doing we're doing good we're
so lucky and I love Blake Shelton how
long was once the colony on the voice
I'm on it still guys I get to be back
fourth time on season 17 does one
Stefani have a twin sister
what no I don't I have a sister though
actually wrote a song called sister
about my sister that nobody's heard that
song it's a really good song my sister's
name is Jill Stefani okay she's a
teacher she's really smart she went to
UCLA and Berkeley so whatever does it
was too funny play any instruments okay
this is the deal so many regrets about
this um I took flute lessons when I was
in eighth grade and I really had a hard
time like learning the flute so I went
on to get into marching band and I
pretended to play the piccolo for a
while and I really wanted to play really
desperately but for some reason it was
just I could never really get get my
head wrapped around it then I never
really played any instruments until I
kind of learned how to play guitar
enough to write a song and
wrote a song called simple kind of life
on the guitar and it's the only song
I've ever written and completely on my
own and yeah and then I then I got long
so I really wish I played an instrument
if you are thinking about playing an
instrument don't give up and you know
what when Stefani it's not too late you
can actually learn to play the guitar
this one Stefani have tattoos absolutely
not no not for me
does once the Bonnie speaks Spanish
Tommy on pizza that's it that's all
gimme a kiss um but again one of those
things that I regret in my life is not
learning another language but I really
did have a hard time learning English so
there's Kwan's the bonnie have a Grammy
yes I do I have three Grammys and I I
had them for a long time and I had them
just in the closet at the house and just
like about a year ago I took all of my
awards out and I like put them in my
office and like it's just it was just
one of those things I was like why are
these in here I should just be inspired
by these and it's fine because then the
kids combined they're like mommy what is
this why did you have this and it's
pretty exciting to be actually
recognized for something and get an
award and I'm grateful is Gwen Stefani
really American Armenian I'm really like
upside down I hate answering this
question because I feel like it lets so
many people down
I'm an American Italian Irish
I'm not Armenian and I do not know at
what point that that rumor got started
but I did live in Los Feliz which is
right by Glendale which is a huge
Armenian neighborhood and Los Angeles
and people would come up to me like
crying and hugging you just because I
thought it was a harmine Ian and I think
it must be something about the eyes like
the dark eyes and anyways I love your
culture and
[Music]
is one Stefani Madonna's cousin I wish
no this is how that rumor got started so
my aunt Donna de Paula she married a
Ciccone which is not really he's not
Uncle Sam was not related to Madonna but
it just happens to have the same name so
yes so Madonna is Italian and I'm
Italian
so what's that is once the Bonnie
related to Lady gaga
um no but just in the airport the other
day someone was going uh like they
thought I was Lady Gaga is when Stefani
pink what that is so funny
I'm not pink and but I love pink is born
Stefani alive thank God yes I am I'm so
grateful to be alive and thank you for
all your googles it's always nice to be
thought about so thank you so much